all right remember the young man from  las vegas we told you about yesterday he  did great on jeopardy last night  the jeopardy clue crew caught up with  braden smith right after he won his  first match  just playing the game is so much fun you  know if i  if i lost the first game i would have  been i would still would have loved it  but um  just being able to to have one under my  belt is just a dream come true  well braden's back at it again tonight  at seven to defend his jeopardy win you  can catch it right here on channel eight  go  brayden seven o'clock tonight jeopardy  another las vegas doing well john alex  sherry  everybody joy of liberty high school  that's all for us here on good day las  vegas have a good rest your day we'll  catch you tomorrow  take care